Scientists in Georgia think they might've
figured out how all life started on Earth.
Yeah, we're about to get real.
Strap in.
Anthony for DNews and if there's one question
we all want the answer to it's "Where did
we come from?"
Researchers at Georgia Institute of Technology
think they've figured out a crucial component
of the answer.
So, about 3.5 billion years ago, the earth
was a lifeless, oxygen free environment.
At some point,
bacteria formed and started converting all
the carbon dioxide and methane and ammonia
and turning it into oxygen.
But we've never been sure where that bacteria
came from.
Earth's oceans at the time were filled with
all kinds of minerals, including iron.
If you've ever heard the term "primordial
soup," that's what we're talking about, earth's
original atmosphere and mineral-filled ocean.
So the idea is that in the soup were all the
things you need to make RNA- the RNA interacted
with something, some sort of chemical reaction
or spark or something, and started creating
that bacteria- and all life on earth.
There have always been a couple problems with
that theory- the first is that RNA isn't really
capable of making life on its own.
Your DNA has all the instructions for making
you and the ability to transfer that information.
RNA basically acts as a messenger, taking
the instructions from your DNA and using them
to make proteins.
Without DNA and protein-based enzymes, RNA
doesn't survive.
The second is that there was nothing in the
environment that anyone could find that would
jumpstart the ability to create life.
One theory is that lightning did it- another
is an impact from space.
But here's what the team in Georgia found-
If they recreated the primordial soup in a
chamber, RNA changed- it behaved differently
in an environment without oxygen.
It was almost like it reactivated a function
it hadn't used in billions of years.
It shape-shifted and all of a sudden became
an instruction-carrier, kind of like DNA - and
when they teamed it up with that iron from
the soup, it performed a single-electron transfer.
That means that it jumpstarted the reactions
needed for photosynthesis and respiration.
RNA together with iron created the basis for
an eating, breathing thing.
BOOM.
LIFE ON EARTH.
Bacteria forms, oxygen is transferred into
the atmosphere, and 3.5 billion years later
we're all reblogging sloth gifs on tumblr.
Now, there are still holes in this theory.
If you asked "Hey, where did that RNA come
from in the beginning of the world," you're
asking the right question.
All the components of RNA were in the soup,
but they're not components that like to bond
easily- though there have been some successes
in making it happen in a lab.
How crazy is that!
RNA, this molecule that we thought was so
simple, that we thought we knew everything
about, was way more adaptive than we thought.
Maybe there's a way to create it that we haven't
thought of, and then we'll be even closer
to figuring out where we came from.
The origin of all life!
So rad.
What's the biggest question you want science
to answer?
Let me know down below and subscribe for more
DNews.
Let me know down on Twitter, we're @Dnews.